no no I was very impressed with look at
my jeans yeah yeah hey Brian I had four
pairs of [ __ ] jeans done what do you
know Eugene jeans up we had have you
done with Adam hemmed so they fit my
legs love this that a little cuz I got
short legs and then I am DUP once you
spike shorter gene the guy did a
terrible job and I'm gonna go back gave
you bell-bottoms yeah that's that looks
cool on you okay look he really cool if
I was in the 70s I want to come back I'm
gonna go to the [ __ ] iron oh my god
hey dude all good do you have a time
machine do you have a time machine here
he gave you the boot cuz if you don't I
got a problem but you just let you they
were too long yeah well should I buy
these or this is for jeans sir it's too
cold I put them on and they were all
they were all here watch this denim I'm
gonna stand up stand up jeans that were
like the same way till they flare out to
the side that's not that bad dude I
haven't seen you once where the gucci
boots we got you I know I bought these
though well really gucci boots look
sweet in those in that outfit I'm very
self-conscious about it where ice yeah
but we're him they're made to be worn
I'm gonna they get better when you wear
in yes a Massachusetts Police Department
released a statement on their Facebook
page saying folks due to the extreme
heat we're asking anyone thinking of
doing criminal activity to hold off
until Monday it is straight up hot as
soccer balls out here conducting
criminal activity in this extreme heat
is next-level henchmen status and also
very dangerous
stay home blast the AC bench stranger
things season three play with the face
app practice karate in your basement we
will all meet again on Monday when it's
cooler sincerely the Popo very good PS
please no spoiler alerts we're fit we're
just finishing season two very funny
well done Braintree police report
Department where's that a massachusett
that funny [ __ ] I guess crime goes up as
you get topics yeah irritated at this
summertime people in Chicago were people
outside but they're also irritated no a
see or get a little crazy that's inch
like Picasso hilarious Bravo Braintree
Police Department funny we will meet
again on Monday and it scoop at sir
Eddie Murphy is apparently close to a
seventy million dollar stand-up deal
with Netflix sale yeah did you see him
on the comedians and cars getting coffee
huh cycles come back yeah he's amazing
and if I think who was it it was uh Oh
Chris Rock and sick in the head on Judd
Apatow's book he talks about Eddie more
their trauma Eddie Murphy and he does
four big fights he always has people
over the house the biggest of the basic
comics over his house and they say Eddie
Murphy just destroy destroy
yeah-oh destroys [ __ ] so Eddie Murphy
here's a thing be because you know
here's I'm sure he's gonna do up he
hasn't been on the circuit he hasn't
been in a while so I'm curious cuz like
Ellen
hasn't been going around doing front and
then she does a special is just a little
different right apparently he's always
hi
apparently always hi always always hi so
I don't know and he that when he was
what he was he wasn't so bein seen see
what weed does to his brain and what
he's doing I don't know let's say yeah
at Eddie Murphy though he's aware of the
kind of the bar that he said so I don't
he went come back it was a bad he said
he has to practice doesn't need money no
he told Jerry Seinfeld he's like oh he
was I'm going to go to clubs like
guarantees that the Comedy Store you
gotta go that's what I mean you got
you've got a practice that's awesome
yeah Eddie Murphy wow did you see [ __ ]
to Lea's video do you see the Instagram
the video he sent me mm-hmm
bring up my Instagram please and don't
say anything don't look just just watch
the video watch this [ __ ] what I
got this morning I had to post it this
let's watch yeah watch this
turn this up
zena's trailer
I can't find what having your career
[Laughter]
jack it's so high moenay's quite so
fired up man I went in the back and I
don't know him at all I went dude
inspiring I think I was too much energy
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah Jesus Christ
thank you mug
I said go so good he's like thanks man
it was so good though man
yeah you know I don't think you know
this but your hugs aren't normal hug I
had idea you know that right because you
used to uh you know choke out people I I
do you don't really know I page between
put to sleep or just hug congratulations
I hugged you before and um I think it
was your your chest muscle was inside of
my throat got too much yeah and you're
lying got you coffee
and I'm like wake me up dude I like a
waitress that's it because I could tell
she's like too much yeah too much cuz I
was a girl what's up I don't she's a
girl oh alright yeah I went too much
brendan is that is that is that
something uh like it like physically
like you you really don't know that
you're uh comic to hide it I don't you
don't know if I'm really excited to see
someone like sometimes with Brian's like
dude that that was intense like really
more like I was I'm shooting this movie
and they go hey we really want you to I
was playing this drunk at a bar and like
we really want you to grab the actor
like really like sling him around like
really like dude he can handle me okay
and so I'm pretend I'm all drunk I
noticed this famous celebrity at the bar
I start grabbing them and I'm like this
and you can tell it's like and we don't
use Jesus Christ give me a second yeah
and he looks at the directors yeah yeah
yeah and the direct comes against so we
like what you're doing we like what
you're doing a little less oh yeah a
little and I'm like what yeah but
remember he told me he can handle you
when we go full-bore like we made a
mistake let's tone it down you're going
for the belt again yeah yeah this is
right oh yeah this isn't you there's no
cage there's no cage you don't see a
fence around you do the out of fact we
got we'd like you to leave we're good
yeah that's movie a matter of fact I'm
Texan
yeah yeah her dad you're out yeah in
fact you're tapping up your meathead
yeah you're attacked out of cards you're
tapped that [ __ ] [ __ ] I was
embarrassed
yeah because they're like to throw them
around and I could tell like he was
trying to still play the role but it was
hurting yeah but you don't know that
you're that physical ah they told me
that like I'm just trying to do my job
but I can't hold you outside and I was
like jolanda's Christ now it's a lot I'm
like a sailor on a [ __ ] arm
I'm guessing but that's exactly what you
are big Sam but you're the big Saint
Bernard you can't get mad at that
[ __ ] thing people can hang around
this no people love Saint Bernards you
should put a kegger exactly like it
change
oh yeah it's a goal big pain that'd be
sad I made it yeah you just flying hug
you just want to sit on the couch and
there that's you yeah dude I love st.
Bernard to finish it so much I'd 100 100
percent you know Doug's know I hate them
love them I loved I have a we have a dog
but it stays at the mommy's house where
my son it's just a lot of too much hair
I'm always on the road but he's such a
cute Kingston's his name kind of dog
it's a shelter we did what they called
much more persons dog now pauper yeah
poor poor poor Doug yeah I mean there it
has been dude look at my teeth so bad so
bad you look 1,000 times yeah man that's
so crazy
I had such bad sleep apnoea little bit
so bad dude you look house Foley is
really how much more well rested now
yeah yeah
fake CPAP machine also thanks money it
takes money thanks money
mmm you say money buy happiness I beg
the difference oh man he's all happy now
oh so happy you can buy happiness it's
on Amazon right there
look at that one tooth though I mean
that is candy corn in the back of my
mouth you got corn nuts that's corn nut
corner right there that's ranch flavored
corn nuts in the back of my mouth and
look at your grill now Holly that's
Keith uh no no
I want to do something big a big
shout-out to dr. Badawi yeah you got to
do some yeah that's bad yeah thank you
yeah that's Benham are you better you
should inspire you by Hawaii my girl
elevator ding where's my son
ding income the hottest milf erupts in
your life with these tits
yeah in my face man and I go oh I let
you I'll tell you oh wow she's gorgeous
ooh oh wow
and I just kind of like go oh that's
crazy like it's like a [ __ ] two
Ferraris so you know you're just like oh
those are big titties and then she
leaves my girls unbelievable you know
what she was unbelievable
she's gonna steal that girls titties on
it who didn't wait your girl said that
yeah I went who didn't stare at her
titties yeah I wasn't gawking at him her
[ __ ] tits right everybody's face in
the elevator
yeah even the 97 year old old lady's
like look at those tits yeah it's not me
being a pervert yeah leave it mi at
Hooters yeah I'm at Hooters am I an
attack order chicken wings in the
elevator yeah well with a [ __ ] on my
chicken wing yeah get your tits out of
my face yeah my girl goes I can't
believe you look at those titties I go
no no I can't believe that you can't you
cannot not see those titties what do you
think my eyes were supposed to do it's
not my fault like did your girl Chico ha
did your girl think that when the
elevator open and the tits came in that
your eyes were just supposed to go well
here's nothing just shut down but this
was the argument I go all right let's
say a giant black guy gets on this
elevator dick down those ankles his dick
is out and you go oh Jesus I go I can't
believe you looked at his fat dick what
are you doing it what do you do your
[ __ ] gay sir everybody look gay
everybody looked at his big dick yeah
that's a no different once I look at his
own dick you can talk to like a mic like
this he was looked at his own dick he
went look at this he mic checks his dick
1 2 1 2
dude he I was like it's no different
than if a guy comes in with the biggest
dick in the world everyone it's a huge
dick units out his fans mmm when a girl
comes on the other is big titties in my
face everybody man a woman goes through
some fat ass - was she facing you or
facing the door
clothes what she came and she was facing
you she came in and that's what she
caught you look these kind of crowded
and my girl was your pretend I'm walking
in your the show me how you're the hot
milf yeah and here I this is my tip show
them show me how you look what what are
you doing why sorry babe I'm sorry I
didn't notice how my guy sorry I'm sorry
it's natural man that's what you in an
elevator
she's it that's a kiss below I'm still
looking for me and Hawaii yeah I got
away